Olá, boa noite.
Boa noite.
Nós estamos entrevistando esta semana os candidatos à presidência da República nas eleições
2026.
Foram convidados os seis candidatos mais bem colocados na pesquisa Quest de 14 de agosto.
A ordem das entrevistas foi decidida num sorteio com a presença de representantes das campanhas.
Hoje nós recebemos aqui no estúdio o candidato Luiz Inácio Lula da Silva, do PT.
Amanhã nosso convidado é Flávio Bolsonaro, do PL, e no sábado Augusto Cury, do Avante.
Nós já entrevistamos Romeu Zema, do Novo, Ronaldo Caiado, do PSD e Renan Santos, do Missão.
Cada entrevista vai ter 40 minutos de duração, com dois blocos e as considerações finais dos candidatos.
Vamos então começar relembrando a trajetória do candidato Lula.
Aos 80 anos, Luiz Inácio Lula da Silva concorre à reeleição, pleiteando um quarto mandato.
Lula nasceu em Caetés, no agreste de Pernambuco, na época um distrito de Garenhuns.
Em 1969, já em São Paulo, começou a trajetória política como metalúrgico e líder de movimentos sindicais.
Ele participou da fundação do Partido dos Trabalhadores no dia 10 de fevereiro de 1980.
Foi deputado federal na Constituinte, de 88, e presidente da República pela primeira vez em 2002,
depois de disputar a quarta eleição.
Lula foi reeleito em 2006 e obteve o terceiro mandato em 2022.
Nas eleições deste ano, concorre ao lado de Geraldo Alckmin, o candidato a vice pelo PSB.
Boa noite, candidato. Muito obrigado pela presença do senhor.
Boa noite.
Boa noite, Trale. Boa noite, Renata.
O tempo da entrevista começa a valer a partir de agora.
Candidato, três inquéritos da Polícia Federal investigam o seu filho, Fábio Luiz Lula da Silva.
A suspeita é de corrupção e tráfico de influência em órgãos federais.
A PF apura se ele usou o fato de ser o seu filho para conduzir negócios de interesse privado,
dentro do Palácio do Planalto, do Ministério da Saúde e também na data breve.
Os policiais federais afirmam também que ele mantinha uma sociedade oculta com outros dois empresários,
Fernando Bittar e a lobista Roberta Luxinger.
O senhor tem dito que é seu filho que tem que provar que é inocente e que, se ele for culpado, não vai haver privilégios.
Mas cabe ao senhor responder pelo governo.
Pergunto, então, ao senhor, que avaliação o senhor faz dessas acusações de corrupção e tráfico de influência na sua gestão?
Veja, primeiro, não tem nenhuma acusação.
São ilações, ilações, ilações tiradas de telefonemas.
Eu conheço isso muito bem, porque já vivi isso.
O que eu tenho dito?
Eu não sou do Ministério Público, eu não sou delegado, eu não sou juiz, eu sou presidente da República e pai do Fábio.
Se o Fábio cometeu qualquer ilícito, qualquer ilícito ele terá que pagar como qualquer cidadão brasileiro que cometer ilícito.
Eu não vou afastar delegado da Polícia Federal, eu não vou fazer qualquer movimento para que meu filho seja comertado, se ele tiver erro, como outros já fizeram.
Ele sabe o que eu passei, sabe o que a minha filha minha passou, ele sabe que a Marisa morreu por conta da falsa acusação que foi feita na Lava Jato.
Portanto, ele tem obrigação de não ter feito erro.
Eu estou muito tranquilo com o presidente da República.
Tudo o que for preciso fazer no âmbito da Polícia e da Justiça para apurar será dado toda e qualquer garantia.
Esse é o comportamento do presidente da República, não é do pai do Fábio, é do presidente da República, que tem que olhar para 215 milhões de brasileiros em igualdade de condições.
Mas, candidato, e as mensagens obtidas pela Polícia Federal no celular dessa lobista Roberta Lucinho?
As mensagens...
Numa das conversas, candidato, ela afirma que seu filho entra em campo quando precisa e que os dois eram uma coisa só.
E ela diz, abre aspas, eu sou o Fábio.
Numa outra mensagem, ela afirma, eu trabalho a política via palácio.
Eu sou boa de costura política.
Os brasileiros não merecem algum tipo de explicação mais robusta diante de tudo isso que a Polícia Federal levantou até agora?
Eu sou a entrada e você é jornalista e você conhece isso melhor do que ninguém.
Eu fui vítima disso na Lava Jato, da maior mentira montada neste país, para evitar que eu fosse presidente da República.
Eu poderia ter feito qualquer coisa para não emprestar depoimento.
Eu fiz questão de emprestar mais de 20 depoimentos.
Fiquei quieto, 80 dias na cadeia, porque somente eu sabia a verdade.
E eu queria provar que a imprensa estava divulgando coisas mentirosas,
que o Moro tinha mentido para a imprensa, que o Deloitte tinha mentido para a imprensa.
Com o meu filho vai acontecer a mesma coisa.
Só ele sabe a verdade.
Se ele fez erro, ele pagará.
Não existe outro jeito.
Ele não será protegido por ser meu filho, por ser meu irmão, nada.
Portanto, ele sabe o que ele tem que fazer.
Ele tem que provar a inocência dele.
E eu tenho certeza que ele vai ser inocente.
Vamos esperar o tempo.
Não haverá da parte da presidência da República um milímetro de movimento para proteger o meu filho.
A acusação está feita, a Polícia Federal está investigando,
a Polícia Federal está vazando as coisas para a imprensa.
E eu espero que aconteça o julgamento.
Se tiver que vir prestar depoimento, ele vai prestar depoimento, vai participar dos inquéritos.
Se ele for culpado, pagará o preço.
Se não for, ele será inocentado.
Candidato, num desses inquéritos, a Polícia Federal traz indícios de que seu filho teria atuado junto ao Palácio do Planalto
para agendar uma reunião entre essa lobista e o então secretário executivo do Ministério da Saúde, conhecido como Berger.
E aí, numa dessas mensagens, a lobista avisa seu filho que chegou à Brasília.
E ele responde, que ótimo, vai com tudo.
É uma relação adequada, candidato?
Você acha que se eu pegasse o seu celular e fosse investigar tudo o que você falou,
só tinha coisa certa, coisa correta?
O que é que uma pilantra pode fazer no telefone?
O que é que um cara qualquer pode fazer no telefone?
Eu estou dizendo para você que o fato de ter pego as conversas no telefone não justifica absolutamente nada.
Até agora não existe uma prova de um centavo público.
Até agora não existe uma prova de uma conversa do meu filho com qualquer ministro.
E eu tenho certeza que ele não fez.
Agora, uma coisa eu vou lhe dizer.
Meu filho vai ser investigado como qualquer cidadão brasileiro.
Agora, candidato, se falou...
Eu estou só na expectativa de que terminar esse inquérito.
Porque o que acontece?
Nós, ele está sendo acusado de uma acusação, de um crime que nós descobrimos na Previdência Social,
criado em 2019, a quadrilha da exploração da Previdência Social.
Nós vamos tocar nesse assunto muito em breve.
Nós, nós, eu vou antecipar para você.
Nós pagamos 5 bilhões de reais, não, pagamos 3 bilhões e meio de reais a 5 milhões de pessoas que foram assaltadas
e já arrecadamos quase que 100 bilhões das coisas que nós tomamos das quadrilhas que estavam montadas.
Portanto, meu cara, é o seguinte, se tem um brasileiro que quer que as coisas estejam investigadas, sou eu.
Agora, o senhor se referiu há pouco sobre essa lobista, e eu gostaria justamente de saber,
porque foi outra mensagem obtida pela Polícia Federal, que diz que essa lobista, Roberta Luxinger,
afirma que o senhor teria oferecido um cargo a ela e dito, que o senhor teria dito para ela,
escolhe onde você quer ficar.
Eu pergunto ao senhor se isso aconteceu, e se o senhor já recebeu esse empresário no Palácio.
Só faltou ela dizer o seguinte, que eu ofereci para ela o Ministério da Defesa,
o Comando da Marinha, da Aeronáutica do Tabarate, é de uma imbecilidade.
Isso aconteceu?
Eu não conheço essa moça, nunca vi essa moça na minha vida, nunca conversei com essa moça,
ela nunca esteve próximo de mim.
É o seguinte, malandro, sabe, é igual em qualquer lugar do mundo.
Convertas por telefone, eu estou acompanhando, eu estou acompanhando.
O caso mais grave do que esse é o do Banco Master, que está silenciado.
Nós vamos também tratar desse assunto, mas antes gostaria de saber a sua avaliação.
É só importante tomar cuidado, que eu não sou nem procurador, nem juiz, nem policial.
A investigação da Polícia Federal envolve também um outro nome muito próximo ao senhor,
que é o seu ex-chefe de gabinete, o Marco Aurélio Santana Ribeiro, conhecido como Marcola.
A Polícia Federal diz que foi ele quem ajudou a agendar essa reunião dessa lobista no Ministério da Saúde
e chegou até a receber a minuta de um contrato que favoreceria a empresa ligada ao careca do INSS,
que é considerado o pivô do escândalo do INSS.
A minha pergunta ao senhor é a seguinte, o senhor não considera que esse tipo de relação
leva suspeitas para dentro do relácio?
Leva, lógico que leva.
Leva suspeita e leva desconfiança para mim, porque o Marco Aurélio é meu chefe de gabinete.
Agora, qual é o papel de chefe de gabinete?
As pessoas sabem que ele é lobista agora que a imprensa está falando que ele é lobista
e que ela foi desendada.
Mas do lado concreto é que o papel dele, que qualquer pessoa que chegar na Presidenta da República
conseguir uma audiência com ele para pedir uma audiência com ninguém,
o papel dele é encaminhar para o Ministério.
Agora, o que nós precisamos saber é o seguinte, essa mulher conseguiu liberar o dinheiro que ela disse que estava atrás.
Ela conseguiu liberar.
Não foi só a questão.
Ela conseguiu liberar o dinheiro.
Tem prova de ter dinheiro público, porque aí é que está o crime.
Aí é que está o crime.
Por isso é que eu não sou precipitado, Renata.
Eu fui acusado de ter um apartamento que eu não tinha,
eu fui acusado de ter uma chácara que eu não tinha
e só foi provada a inocência quando o processo foi anulado.
Portanto, como eu não sou juiz, eu vou muito devagar com isso.
Eu não gosto de fazer pirotecnia com acusações sem que você termine o inquérito.
Então, para saber...
Todos eles, todos eles que foram citados, todos eles que participaram, o caminho é um só.
É o caminho da apuração, da investigação ou da inocência ou da condenação se tiver cometido crime.
Sobre a apuração, a Polícia Federal apurou mais.
Ela disse também que essa lobista não só teria, por intermédio do seu ex-chefe de gabinete,
conseguido a tal reunião, mas ela também pagou despesas pessoais do seu, então, chefe de gabinete.
Boletos, parcelas de financiamento de um carro, faturas de cartão de crédito.
Ele ganhou ainda joias, pediu a ela um quadro no valor de 100 mil euros.
O Marcola disse que, de fato, foi um empréstimo de 249 mil reais que ele devolveu esse dinheiro.
Mas eu pergunto ao senhor, é adequado o chefe de gabinete, a presidência da República,
ganhar joias e ter contas pagas por uma lobista com interesse em contratos do governo?
O senhor sabia dessa relação que se passava na antessala do seu gabinete?
Deixa eu contar uma coisa para você.
Não é adequado, é totalmente errado.
E o Marcola sabe do erro que ele cometeu, porque não é esse o papel do chefe de gabinete.
Ele sabe disso.
Ele sabe da importância de ter chefe de gabinete.
Agora, ele disse que tomou 249 mil reais de emprestado, é o que está na imprensa.
Só ele sabe a verdade, se ele tomou ou não.
Quando tiver uma acariação entre os dois, é que vai saber se foi empréstimo ou não.
Eu, por enquanto, acredito na versão dele de que foi empréstimo.
Acredito na versão dele.
Por que ele não pediu empréstimo a um banco?
Por que ele não falou comigo?
Eu disse para ele, cara, eu sou quase que nem seu pai.
Por que você não falou comigo?
Por que você não falou comigo do problema que você estava tendo?
Agora, é o seguinte, ele cometeu o erro, ele pagará pelo erro que eu cometeu.
É isso que vai acontecer.
Era uma pessoa da minha total confiança, trabalha comigo há sete anos,
todo o tempo que eu fiquei preso em Brasil e no Paraná.
Ele ficou o tempo inteiro lá.
Agora, eu cometei o erro, pago o preço do erro cometido.
É isso.
E eu espero que a polícia cumpra com a sua função,
eu espero que o Ministério Público cumpra com a sua função
e o juiz faça o julgamento que for necessário fazer,
de acordo com os autos do processo.
O que eu não me deixo impactar é por relações.
Eu conheço muito, muito, e já fui vítima muito disso.
Então, eu estou muito tranquilo com relação a isso.
Muito deprimido e muito chateado.
Porque o meu filho sabe que não poderia cometer nenhum erro.
Se cometer, eu vou pagar.
O Marcola sabe que não poderia cometer nenhum erro.
É assim que funciona.
Candidato, o senhor há pouco citou o escândalo do INSS.
Então, nós vamos entrar agora nesse assunto aqui com o senhor.
Nesse escândalo, para a gente refrescar a memória,
mais de 4 milhões de aposentados e pensionistas brasileiros
foram vítimas desses descontos ilegais.
As fraudes aconteceram entre 2019 e 2024,
podem ter passado de 6 bilhões de reais.
E as investigações revelaram que mais de 60% desses descontos sob suspeita
aconteceram no seu governo.
O presidente do INSS no seu governo, ele está preso preventivamente.
O Alessandro Stefanuto, ele é investigado por corrupção,
organização criminosa, lavagem de dinheiro, entre outros crimes.
Que explicação que o senhor dá hoje a esses aposentados e pensionistas?
Nós já demos a explicação.
Primeiro que nós já devolvemos 3 milhões e meio de reais.
3 milhões e meio de reais.
Não tem um aposentado que foi roubado e que não foi devolvido dinheiro.
E esse dinheiro vai ser ressarcido pelos bens que nós aprendemos da quadrilha.
Uma quadrilha que foi montada em 2019,
inclusive com a participação do ministro da Previdência daquela época.
E nós passamos dois anos investigando,
tanto a CGU quanto a Política Federal.
Investigando, porque se a gente faz a denúncia
antes da gente ter o processo como um todo,
a gente atrapalharia facilitando os bandidos.
E nós fizemos questão de colocar na cadeia as pessoas.
Fizemos questão de pagar.
E vamos fazer questão de ressarcir os cofes públicos
com os bens que nós aprendemos deles.
Agora, fato é que no segundo ano do seu mandato,
a quantidade de descontos suspeitos de legalidade
mais do que triplicou em relação a 2022.
E o seu então ministro da Previdência, Carlos Lupe,
foi alertado de que havia indícios de irregularidades.
Ele soube disso em 2023, ou seja,
dois anos antes da operação da Polícia Federal
revelar o escândalo.
O Lupe teve tempo para agir,
mas ele só suspendeu os contratos
um ano depois de saber,
de tomar conhecimento dos fatos.
Que explicações ele deu para o senhor?
Renata, nem os contratos foram suspensos pelo Lupe.
Nós fomos a fundo para investigar,
porque a gente não queria que a Aquarilha se desmontasse.
Mas demorou.
Demorou.
Demorou porque a investigação demora.
Que explicação?
O senhor ficou satisfeito com a explicação?
A explicação é que a Polícia Federal
trabalhou com muita seriedade.
A CGU trabalhou com muita seriedade para investigar.
Levou dois anos.
O dado concreto é que a Aquarilha foi montada em 2019,
foi presa por nós,
descoberta por nós.
Os previdenciários receberam o seu dinheiro de volta
e nós vamos receber o que a Previdência pagou para a quadrilha.
É simples.
O senhor pediu explicação?
Ele saiu do governo.
Ninguém nunca reconhece,
ninguém nunca reconhece que tinha corrupção.
Precisou a CGU e a Polícia Federal investigar.
E é assim que funciona, Renata.
Não tem outro jeito de funcionar.
Tem coisas que passam 80 anos para se apurar,
não se apura.
No nosso caso,
no nosso caso,
a Polícia Federal,
a CGU,
a AGU,
trabalham para que a gente coloque de pé
toda e qualquer denúncia que aparecer.
O senhor disse que pediu explicações a Lupe
e que ele saiu do governo.
Mas, recentemente,
o senhor subiu num palanque com o Carlos Lupe,
fez elogios a ele,
recebeu apoio dele.
Então, pergunto ao senhor,
o senhor não vê problema em pedir voto
ao lado de alguém que demorou para agir,
para barrar os desvios?
E foi o responsável pela indicação
do presidente do INSS,
que está preso?
Deixa eu lhe falar uma coisa.
Ele não está condenado.
Ele é um cidadão livre.
Você acha que você pode deixar de conversar
com uma pessoa que é sua amiga,
que foi,
cometeu um erro,
se a pessoa está em liberdade
e não está condenado?
Não é conversa.
É pedir elogios.
Fazer elogios.
Não, elogios não.
Deixa eu lhe contar uma coisa.
A relação política não tem nada a ver
com a relação administrativa.
Se ele tivesse cometido,
ou a Polícia Federal já tivesse acusado,
ele já tivesse sido condenado,
era uma coisa.
Ele não está.
Então, vamos aguardar, Renata.
Vamos aguardar a investigação.
Eu sei o que é isso, Renata,
porque eu já passei por isso.
Você sabe, como jornalista,
que eu fui vítima
da maior mentira montada
nesse país,
que tinha como objetivo
não me deixar ser candidato em 2018,
tinha como objetivo
desmontar a indústria
de engenharia desse país,
e criar uma imagem negativa
da Petrobras.
Eu coloquei a minha cara
e falei, eu vou.
Eu poderia ter saído do Brasil.
Eu decidi, eu vou para a cadeia
que eu quero provar
que o Moro é mentiroso,
quero provar
que o Dallau é mentiroso
e quero provar
que a imprensa
um dia vai pedir desculpa.
Porque a imprensa brasileira
comprou,
comprou uma mentira,
vendeu a mentira
e nunca reconheceu
que comprou a mentira.
Candidato,
o jornalismo da Globo
cumpriu a sua obrigação
de noticiar os fatos
durante essa conferência.
É de feito pedir desculpa.
A imprensa brasileira
sabe que ela
produziu um monstro
mentiroso
chamado Moro,
chamado Dallau.
Eu não esqueço
do PowerPoint
mentiroso contra mim.
Eu não esqueço.
Agora,
eu me dispuso...
Candidato,
em relação a essa...
Me dispuso aí para a cadeia.
O senhor falou do PowerPoint.
Eu só quero dizer ao senhor
por favor,
em relação a essa questão
do PowerPoint.
Nossos princípios editoriais,
nós fizemos a devida retratação
sobre esse assunto.
Então,
eu peço que a gente
siga com a entrevista
ainda sobre esse assunto
tão importante
para o Brasil
que se chama
Previdência Social.
Além de todos
esses descontos indevidos,
essa fraude bionária,
que começou em 2019,
23, 24,
foi descoberta só depois.
Tem um problema sério
hoje ainda no Brasil
que afeta
aposentados e pensionistas,
que é a fila do INSS.
Quando o senhor assumiu
esse terceiro mandato,
o senhor prometeu
zerar essa fila,
não zerou a fila,
hoje ela está na casa
de 1 milhão
e 300 mil pessoas.
Então,
eu pergunto ao senhor
o que é que o senhor
vai fazer,
se releito,
para oferecer mais qualidade
nesse serviço
essencial
para os brasileiros.
Se você prometer
que vai à Brasília,
eu,
a semana que vem,
vou anunciar
que a fila zerou.
a espera
de 45 dias
vai estar
apenas em
250 mil pessoas,
que é o normal.
Você não pode
deixar de dizer,
Trale,
que no meu governo,
os aposentados
recebiam
aposentadoria,
recebiam uma carta
em casa
dizendo,
você tem tempo
de aposentadoria,
pode me receber.
Uma mulher
que dava a luz,
ela recebia o pré-natal
quase junto
com a criança.
Uma pessoa
que estava doente
era imediatamente.
As pessoas
recebiam em carta
aos benefícios.
Eles desmontaram,
desmontaram o Brasil,
desmontaram a Previdência.
Nós chegamos
a ter 3 milhões
de pessoas na fila
e nós vamos
entregar agora
a fila terminada
na Previdência Social.
Você está convidado
antecipadamente
para ir à Brasília
assistir o ato
em que a gente
vai comemorar
com os aposentados.
A semana que vem.
Candidato,
caso Master,
um aliado histórico
seu aparece
nas investigações.
Jacques Wagner,
que até junho
era líder
do governo
no Senado.
A Polícia Federal
apura se ele recebeu
um apartamento
com propina
em troca
de promover
interesses
do banqueiro
Daniel Vorcaro
na Bahia
e no Senado.
Apesar dessa investigação,
o senhor continuou
demonstrando apoio
e pediu,
inclusive,
votos
para o Jacques Wagner.
Por isso,
eu lhe pergunto,
antes de pedir votos
para ele,
não é preciso
aguardar
as investigações
desse caso,
esclarecer,
de fato,
o envolvimento dele
nesse caso?
O Banco Master
causou um prejuízo
a esse país
de 60 bilhões
de reais.
60 bilhões,
não foi 60 dólares,
foi 60 bilhões de reais.
E tem muita gente
nesse país
envolvido.
Até agora
não está provado
que o Wagner
tem relação
com o Banco Master.
O Wagner
tem relação
com o Augusto,
que na época
não era nem
do Banco Master.
o que eu não posso
admitir para mim
e aceitar
é que eu possa
fazer política
vivendo de ilações
todo santo dia.
Você tem um processo,
tem uma apuração,
tem uma investigação,
as pessoas são inocentes
até prova em contrário.
As pessoas são inocentes
Se um dia,
Renata,
você for acusada,
você é torta
para você ter amigo
que acha que você é inocente
até provar sua culpa.
Mas pedir voto
para ele
antes das investigações
de serem a cair?
Ele é senador da República,
é candidato à reeleição,
é um homem
que tem relação
comigo há 45 anos,
desde o tempo
de sindicalista.
Eu não posso
colocar em dúvida
o comportamento
e a relação
do Wagner comigo
por conta
de uma ilação.
Não posso.
E posso dizer
que eu tenho consciência
que o Wagner
é honesto.
Tenho consciência.
Se ele cometer
um desvio,
vai acontecer
com ele
o que vai acontecer
com qualquer pessoa
vai pagar
o preço
do erro que cometeu.
eu não sou
uma pessoa
que muda
de calçada
quando encontro
um amigo
que está sendo
acusado
de alguma coisa,
não.
Até prova
em contrário
todos são inocentes.
Candidato,
vamos falar
de contas públicas
e ajustes
de calça.
Eu acho que é
da hora de falar
porque eu estava
parecendo
que eu estava
no Ministério Público.
Candidato,
a dívida pública
no seu governo
ultrapassou
os 10 trilhões
de reais.
E além do tamanho
da dívida,
o problema é a direção
que ela está tomando.
A gente chama
de trajetória
da dívida.
O seu governo,
a dívida disparou
10 pontos percentuais,
atingiu 82%
do PIB.
E essa trajetória,
ela pressiona
os juros
que encarecem
o crédito,
que dificulta
o investimento
e que pesa
no bolso das famílias.
O seu programa
de governo
menciona
uma necessidade
de um ajuste fiscal,
mas não traz
metas explícitas
para os próximos
quatro anos.
Então,
eu quero saber
do senhor
quais são
as suas metas
e para que percentual
do PIB
o senhor pretende
trazer essa dívida.
Renata,
eu pensei
que uma jornalista
da tua qualidade,
da tua competência,
pudesse começar
essa pergunta
falando diferente,
Renata.
Você pode dizer,
presidente Lula,
o senhor
foi o único
presidente
na história
do Brasil
que fez superávit
primário
durante oito anos
do seu primeiro mandato.
dos países
do G20
eu fui o único
que fez superávit
primário
durante oito anos.
Nunca tive
problema fiscal
nesse país.
Você acha
que o Brasil
está com problema
de dívida pública
porque nós chegamos
a 80%?
Sabe por quê?
Porque nós temos
há mais de dez anos
sem crescer.
Você sabe
quando é que o PIB
voltou a crescer
acima de 2%,
Renata?
Quando eu voltei
à presidência
da República.
Você se esquece
que eu deixei
esse país crescendo
7,5% em 2010?
Você se esquece
que eu deixei
esse país crescendo
7,5%
e quando eu voltei
ele estava crescendo
1%,
ele só cresceu
3%,
sabe,
em 2023,
2024,
2025.
Então deixa eu
te falar uma coisa.
Na medida que você
começa a crescer
a economia,
o PIB começa a cair
com ela,
a dívida começa a cair
em relação à dívida.
80% de dívida,
sabe,
um país,
não é muito
se você olhar
para os Estados Unidos,
olhar para o Japão,
e ir para a Itália.
Essa trajetória
do PIB...
Você sabe qual é a dívida
dos Estados Unidos?
120% do PIB
é 40 trilhões de dólares.
Olha,
o que é importante
é o seguinte,
uma dívida,
sabe,
uma parte dela
é por conta
da taxa de juros,
que você defenderam
a vida inteira
o Banco Central
independente.
Candidato,
o seu ministro...
Você está lembrado,
o Fernando Henrique Cardoso
trocou 3 presidente
do Banco Central.
eu entrei,
disse que,
dois anos,
como presidente
do Bolsonaro.
Porque se você
não fizer a pergunta
completa,
eu vou dizer para você,
a mim não preocupa
a dívida pública.
Eu vou dizer por quê.
Eu herdei esse governo
em janeiro de 2023
com déficit fiscal
de 2,8%.
Você sabe
o quanto vai ser
o orçamento
desse ano?
Superar o primário
de 0,1%.
Portanto,
se tem alguém
nesse país
que tem responsabilidade
fiscal,
sou eu.
E nem a trajetória
da dívida o preocupa.
Eu quero a trajetória
de marcar a taxa de juros.
Porque tem uma coisa
que nós temos
que entender,
Renata.
Nós
pegamos esse país
numa situação
que nós não tínhamos
orçamento
para governar.
Você está lembrado
da PEC da transição?
A PEC da transição
foi inclusive
para pagar
o roubo
deixado pelo outro governo.
Deixou um roubo
de 94 bilhões
sabe
de dívida
com as pessoas
que nós tivemos
que pagar.
Eu quero aproveitar
esse assunto ainda,
candidato.
Eu, sinceramente,
Renata,
eu tenho uma coisa
que eu digo sempre.
Responsabilidade
eu apedico
a dona Lindor.
Ela juntava os filhos,
pegava o dinheiro
e falava
vocês não podem
comprar
e gastar
o que vocês não têm.
Eu vou dizer uma coisa
para vocês lembrar.
Em dezembro
de 2008,
por ocasião
da crise do subprime
nos Estados Unidos,
o comércio
entrou numa crise.
Eu fui para a televisão,
fiz um discurso
de oito minutos,
convocando a sociedade
brasileira
a consumir.
porque era verdade
que estava tendo
desemprego,
mas se ele não consumir
ia ter mais desemprego
ainda.
Consuma com responsabilidade.
Se você
consumir com responsabilidade,
você vai poder
pagar a sua dívida
e o país
vai voltar a crescer.
Foi o ano
em que a classe
C e D
consumiram mais
do que a classe
em B.
Então,
se tem uma coisa
que baliza a minha vida,
chama-se
responsabilidade fiscal.
E eu tenho
uma equipe econômica
que era do Haddad,
que era do Guido,
que agora é do Daril,
com muita rede
portada fiscal.
Eu sei o que eu quero
desse país.
Eu sempre quero
ter candidato outra vez.
Aproveitando,
então,
agora que o senhor
acaba de tocar
no nome do seu
ministro da Fazenda,
do Daril Durigan,
eu queria entrar
muito nesse assunto
agora com o senhor,
que é o seguinte,
o próprio ministro
da Fazenda do senhor
tem manifestado
preocupação
com a rolagem
da dívida pública.
Ele disse que
o próximo governo
vai ter que fazer
ajustes fiscais,
vai ter que reduzir
gastos obrigatórios.
Então,
eu pergunto ao senhor
o seguinte,
o senhor pretende
reduzir gastos
obrigatórios?
Porque é muito importante
esclarecer isso
para a sociedade
e para a população.
E se o senhor
pretende reduzir
gastos obrigatórios,
quais exatamente?
Que compromisso
que o senhor estabelece
se reeleito?
O meu estabelecimento
é o seguinte,
é fazer esse país
crescer.
A minha proposta
de ser candidato
a presidente
da República
outra vez,
é porque eu já fiz
o bado que eu tinha
que fazer.
Você está lembrado
que eu comecei
em 2003
dizendo que ao terminar
o meu mandato,
cada brasileiro
estiver almoçando,
tomando café e jantando,
eu terei realizado
a obra da minha vida.
Eu fiz mais do que isso.
Depois eu fiz o PAC
no segundo mandato.
Depois eu fiz o PAC 3,
agora,
nesse mandato,
com 1 trilhão
e 900 bilhões
de investimentos,
dos quais,
até 2026,
agora em dezembro,
são 1 trilhão
e 340 bilhões,
dos quais 97%
já quitados.
Então,
o que eu quero
para o próximo mandato?
Eu quero fazer
uma revolução
tecnológica
nesse país.
Eu quero voltar
a fazer com que
esse país
seja disputar
com o mundo rico.
Esse país
vai ter que ser
dono do minerais críticos
e da terra rara.
Esse país
vai ter que aportar
numa inteligência artificial
com linguagem portuguesa.
Esse país
vai ter que tentar
fazer uma reforma
para que a gente tenha
a nossa defesa
tomando conta
de 8 milhões
e meio de quilômetros
quadrados
que está totalmente
abandonado.
e nós estamos vendo
que nós temos,
depois da China,
possivelmente,
a gente esteja um país
que tenha mais minérias críticas
e terras raras.
E você percebe
que está sendo vendido
enquanto a gente
não faz a regulação.
Eu estive com a Columbre
essa semana
pedindo para ele
vamos aprovar
a regulação
para que a gente
não permita
que as nossas riquezas
sejam vendidas
porque isso,
se a gente souber
extrair,
transformar
e produzir
os materiais
que a gente pode,
fazer bateria,
fazer chip,
fazer celular
aqui dentro do Brasil,
a gente vai estar
criando um passaporte
para dar oportunidade
para a juventude brasileira
ter orgulho
de que no seu país
ela vai ter condições
de estudar,
de trabalhar
e de ganhar a sua vida.
É esse o futuro
que eu quero para o país.
E é por isso
que eu estou
prestando o quarto mandato,
porque eu já acabei
com a fome duas vezes.
Duas.
Você sabe
que quando eu voltei agora
esse país estava
destruído,
destruído.
O déficit
era 2,8%.
O último foi 0,8%.
E agora,
nesse orçamento,
vai ser positivo.
Nós vamos fazer
superávit
esse ano.
Candidato,
depois...
Porque eu...
Sabe o que acontece,
Sr. Trale?
Eu aprendi muito cedo.
Posso avançar
nos assuntos,
por favor?
Eu ganho,
eu não vou conseguir
realizar nada.
Eu vou me perder.
Então,
eu tenho...
Na próxima pergunta,
eu vou lhe contar
a minha conversa
com o FMI.
Esse país aqui...
Porque se a gente
não contar,
a meninada
que está ouvindo a gente
não entende.
Esse país aqui
devia 30 bilhões de dólares.
Esse país aqui,
o Malan,
não conseguia
uma audiência com o FMI.
Esse país aqui
não podia pagar
suas importações.
Quando eu assumi
a presidência,
todos os economistas
diziam que o país
estava quebrado.
Pois bem,
o país não quebrou.
Eu paguei 30 bilhões
do FMI.
Fui na primeira reserva
de dólar
desse país
de 270 bilhões de reais,
que é o que segura
a estabilidade econômica
desse país até hoje.
Ainda falando
sobre economia,
sobre essa questão
de dívida pública,
quero muito ouvir o senhor
sobre a crise
nas estatais.
As estatais brasileiras
federais estão acumulando
um prejuízo
de 20 bilhões de reais
no seu governo.
E o caso
mais emblemático,
mais grave,
é o dos Correios.
Já são
quatro anos seguidos
de prejuízo.
É um rombo histórico.
São 15 bilhões
de reais,
candidato.
A própria direção
da estatal
diz que parte da crise
se deve
a baixa qualidade
na operação
da empresa.
Não ter eficiência
num setor
cada vez mais competitivo
significa risco
de prejuízo.
O senhor considera
vender os Correios?
Eu tinha que falar
uma coisa,
candidato.
Você já era nascido
em 1985.
Desde 1985
correu...
Nós estamos de volta
com o segundo bloco
da entrevista
com Luiz Inácio
Lula da Silva,
candidato do PT
à presidência
da República.
Candidato,
vamos falar de educação?
Vamos.
Vamos falar
do acesso à escola
entre jovens
de 4 a 17 anos
que está na casa
dos 97%
está perto
da universalização,
o que é bom.
Mas a gente sabe
que acesso
não é a mesma coisa
que aprendizagem.
E um estudo
do Todos pela Educação,
divulgado agora
em agosto,
mostra que
seis em cada
dez jovens brasileiros
terminam o ensino médio
na rede pública
sem aprender
o básico
em matemática.
Eu quero saber
do senhor
por que esse resultado
e qual é o seu plano
para melhorar
se o senhor for reeleito?
Então,
deixa eu te dizer
uma coisa,
Renata.
Se tem uma coisa
que eu tenho orgulho
é que o Brasil
nunca teve
um presidente da República
que cuidasse
da educação
como eu cuidei.
Eu sou o presidente
da República
que mais coloquei
aluno
na escola
de tempo integral.
Nós fizemos
um pacto
com os prefeitos
para a alfabetização
das crianças
na idade certa
que a gente previa
até 2030
chegar a 80%
dos jovens.
Chegamos a 66%
no primeiro ano
desse acordo.
Porque as coisas
estão evoluindo muito.
Eu criei o Fundeb
para garantir
que os meninos
do ensino médio
não desistissem da escola.
500 mil
desistiam por ano
para ajudar
no orçamento familiar.
Nós precisamos
o Bolsa Família
ou melhor,
nós criamos
o pé de meia
garantindo
uma conta,
uma poupança
para os jovens
para eles não
desistirem da escola.
Isso diminuiu
a invasão
no primeiro ano
em mais de 60%
dos alunos.
E sou o presidente
que mais fiz
universidade
nesse país,
mais fiz
institutos federais.
dos quase 800 institutos
desse país,
80%
foi feito por mim
e pela Dilma.
E com relação
a essa dificuldade
do aprendizado?
Veja,
a dificuldade
do aprendizado,
você tem que entender
o Estado como o Ceará,
a molecada
é mais evoluída
que em São Paulo.
O que,
na verdade,
a educação básica,
ela é administrada
pelo Estado.
O governo
tem o Fundeb
que ajuda os Estados.
Mas cada Estado
age de um jeito.
o Ceará
e o Piauí
são os Estados
pobres
que têm
o melhor nível
de educação
nesse país.
Você sabia
que 40%
dos alunos
que passam
no vestibular
do ITA
em São Paulo
e em São Paulo
são cearese?
Por isso,
eu levei o ITA
para Fortaleza
como premiação.
Você sabe
que nós criamos
aqui no Rio de Janeiro
uma faculdade
da matemática
para premiar
os alunos
que participam
das Olimpíadas
da matemática,
os que têm
medalhas de ouro.
Nós fazemos
um vestibular
entre eles
e os 400
melhores
estão
numa faculdade
de matemática
aqui
com dormida,
comida,
porque a gente
não quer perder
mais gênio.
E os especialistas
em educação
dizem que é muito
importante investir
na formação
dos professores.
Qual é
a sua proposta
para isso?
Então,
eu vou lhe dizer,
sabe o que nós fizemos?
Nós estamos dando
uma bolsa de estudo
para o menino
do Enem
que passar
em primeiro lugar,
que for ser professor,
ele vai ganhar
uma bolsa de estudo
para estudar
para o professor.
porque normalmente
ele não quer
os melhores,
que é outra coisa.
E nós estamos
dando uma bolsa
porque nós sabemos
que a qualidade
do professor
influencia,
sabe,
na formação
do aluno.
Então,
candidato,
para a gente
falar de um outro tema,
pois não.
quem criou a Olimpíada
da Matemática
no Brasil,
na escola pública,
fui eu,
contra a vontade
de muita gente
que dizia que as crianças
não gostavam
de matemática.
Na primeira inscrição
entrou 10 milhões
de crianças,
na segunda
14 milhões de crianças,
na terceira
18 milhões de crianças.
E quando as crianças
aprendem
a desfiar,
o casulo da matemática
passa a ser a matéria
que ele mais mostra.
Então,
agora,
no futuro,
por isso que eu quero
um quarto mandato,
nós precisamos colocar
muita gente
para fazer matemática,
para fazer engenharia,
muita gente
para aprender
esse mundo digital
e discutir
inteligência artificial,
porque nós
não queremos
ficar subordinados
à briga
dos Estados Unidos
com a China.
Agora,
antes de encerrar,
eu gostaria de ouvir
do senhor
sobre um tema
muito importante
que é segurança pública.
Uma das maiores
preocupações do brasileiro.
Exato.
Nos últimos 24 anos
do nosso tempo,
é importante
a gente falar
de segurança.
Nos últimos 24 anos,
17 foram
do PCOM-PT
na presidência.
O senhor está
no terceiro mandato,
são 12 anos
na cadeira
de presidente.
Na sua avaliação,
candidato,
por que,
nesses mais de 20 anos,
o crime organizado
se espalhou pelo Brasil?
É importante
que a gente
contribua
para formar
as pessoas
que estão
nos assistindo.
Na Constituição
de 88,
a Constituição
aprovou
que a segurança
pública
era da responsabilidade
do Estado.
A sociedade
devia estar
cansada
dos militares
terem
gerência
nas políticas
estaduais
e nós,
então,
a pedido
de todos
os progressistas
da Constituinte,
demos para o Estado.
O governo federal
ficou com a política
federal,
com a política
rodoviária federal
e com a polícia
penal.
Eu estou discutindo
no Congresso Nacional,
fui colocado
para votar agora,
por isso que eu almocei
com o Columbre
e com o Hugo Mota,
votar a PEC
da Segurança Pública,
porque a hora
que for aprovar
a PEC
da Segurança Pública,
eu crio
o Ministério
da Segurança Pública.
Por que
que eu vou criar
o Ministério?
Porque,
primeiro,
eu quero estabelecer
qual é a participação
de cada ente federado
da Segurança Pública,
qual vai ser
o papel da União,
o papel do Estado
e qual vai ser
o papel do município.
Porque,
aí sim,
a gente vai trabalhar
muito forte,
talvez desmanado.
Teve muitos governadores
que não quiseram,
Tarfísio não quis,
Caiado não quis,
porque não querem
que o governo federal
se meta na Segurança Pública.
Candidato,
aproveitando,
então,
posso aproveitar
esse gancho
que o senhor falou
da coordenação
entre governadores,
a PEC da Segurança,
que o senhor está tentando
passar no Congresso Nacional.
Lembrando,
então,
que o senhor vai completar
12 anos como presidente.
O PT governa a Bahia
tem 20 anos.
E a Bahia,
hoje,
tem 5 das 10 cidades
mais violentas do Brasil.
O maior número
de mortes violentas
de crianças e adolescentes
é o triplo
da média nacional.
Por que
que o PT
não tem conseguido
coordenar ações eficientes
sem segurança
na Bahia,
mesmo governando
o país
e o Estado
ao mesmo tempo
e há tanto tempo,
candidato?
Não seja injusto
com a Bahia.
Nenhum
governador do Brasil,
nenhum
conseguiu
receber o problema
da segurança pública.
Nenhum
conseguiu segurar.
Se você pegar
do Iapau,
cachorro,
ninguém conseguiu.
Ninguém.
Você é de São Paulo,
eu trago.
Mas nem tem
o governo do Estado
e o governo federal,
candidato?
E você,
muito menino,
cansou de ver
as campanhas
do Marluxo lá em São Paulo?
Bandido bom é bandido morto?
Cansou de ver
carreta passeando
com um artista
fantasiado de prisioneiro?
Ninguém consegue resolver.
Só vai conseguir
se a gente tiver
muito investimento
em inteligência.
É isso que eu quero fazer.
O que é que eu quero fazer?
Aprovando a PEC,
nós vamos criar
o Ministério da Segurança Pública,
vamos definir
qual é o papel
da política federal
nos Estados,
porque você sabe
que a política federal
não pode investigar
crime nos Estados,
a não ser que seja
crime federal.
e nem sempre
os governadores pedem.
Se não fosse a política federal,
a gente não pegava
o assassino da Mariela aqui.
E o governador
não queria que a gente
viesse investigar.
Então,
o que é que eu quero?
Nós fizemos agora,
aprovamos uma lei de infracção,
estamos trabalhando
na questão do combate
ao crime organizado,
por isso eu fui levar
para o Trump
uma proposta por inscritos.
Se os Estados Unidos
quiserem trabalhar
junto com o Brasil
para combater o narcotráfico,
o crime organizado,
o Brasil está pronto
e preparado.
Montamos uma base
da política federal
em Manaus
para tomar conta
da fronteira
com representantes
de policiais
de cada país
da América do Sul
para que a gente
possa enfrentar.
Por quê?
Qual é o meu desejo?
O meu desejo
é recuperar
o território
para o povo.
Sabe,
aquela rua
é do povo do Rio,
não é do bandido.
A escola
é do povo,
não é do bandido.
O bairro
é da escola.
Nós precisamos,
então,
enfrentar isso.
E enfrentar uma coisa
mais grave
que é enfrentar
o do andar de cima.
Como nós fizemos
a Operação Carbono
Culto,
que foi a maior
operação já feita
na história desse país.
Nós estamos preparados
para muitas operações.
O que eu quero
é que prefeituras
importantes,
como o Rio de Janeiro,
São Paulo,
tem que ter policial
com a ação de policial.
Não pode ficar o policial
sem poder prender.
Se a gente fizer
uma combinação
de criar uma espécie
de susto
da segurança pública
e a gente trabalhar
conjuntamente,
eu posso ter garantido
que o Paulo Valdir
vai ganhar.
E por isso
que eu fui conversar
com a Columbre.
Vamos aprovar a PEC.
Porque aprovando a PEC,
eu crio o Ministério
na semana seguinte.
E depois de criar
o Ministério,
não é que ele vai
funcionar rapidamente, não.
Eu vou ter que convencer
o Daniel,
que está assistindo
o programa daqui,
de que ele tem
que colocar recursos.
Porque a gente
tem uma polícia
eficiente
e a gente acabar
com o crime organizado.
A gente vai ter
que ter muito dinheiro.
Candidato,
o nosso tempo acabou.
Eu peço agora
que o senhor faça
as suas considerações finais,
a sua despedida do eleitor.
O senhor tem um minuto.
Renata e Trale
e telespectadores
sabem que estão nos assistindo.
Eu quero dizer para vocês
que eu vivo hoje,
há uns 80 anos,
o melhor momento
da minha passagem
pelo planeta Terra.
Eu tenho consciência
do que nós fizemos
nesse país.
Eu tenho dito
para todo mundo
que se você pesquisar
desde a proclamação
da República
até o dia de hoje,
você não vai encontrar
nenhum governo
que fez a quantidade
de política
de inclusão social
que nós fizemos.
É muito estranho dizer
que o metalúrgico
sem diploma universitário
é o presidente
que mais fez
universidade nesse país.
É muito estranho dizer
que o presidente
sem diploma universitário
foi o que fez
mais instituto federal
nesse país.
É importante dizer
que quando eu cheguei
na presidência,
nós temos 5 milhões
de trabalhadores
no mercado de trabalho
com diploma universitário.
Hoje nós temos
25 milhões
e eu quero chegar
a 50,
porque eu quero
que o Brasil
seja exportador
de inteligência
e de conhecimento.
Eu não quero
que o Brasil
continue exportando
minerais,
minério de ferro,
soja e milho,
sabe,
que é muito importante,
mas é importante
a gente exportar
inteligência
que é isso
que vai dar competitividade.
nós vamos fazer
um forte investimento
em educação,
vamos apresentar
um plano de educação.
Terminou o tempo,
candidato.
Quero agradecer
muito a entrevista,
muito obrigado
aqui pela sua presença.
Obrigado, Trano,
obrigado, Renata.
Obrigada.
Amanhã,
o nosso entrevistado
é Flávio Bolsonaro,
candidato Flávio Bolsonaro
do PL.
Boa noite.
Boa noite,
muito obrigado
e até amanhã.
E aí